there is a lot that we still don't know
about
the shooter in georgia who tragically
killed eight people at a massage parlor
on tuesday but it increasingly seems
that the early claims that race was not
a motivating factor
for the shooter those claims appear to
be falling apart
including based on some new witness
testimony given to
a south korean newspaper that has been
covering the story so to catch everybody
up
the suspect is a 21 year old male he is
alive he was taken into custody
on tuesday after this horrific shooting
at a massage parlor in georgia that left
at last count eight dead and one injured
and police have had a chance to
interview him this doesn't always happen
in these situations where the shooter
either at their own hand or that of the
police
uh often will end up dead not the case
here
police speak to the shooter and the
initial
belief by many was this was clearly
an anti-asian hate crime this was an
individual targeting
asian individuals but then it wasn't so
clear
and um it it could be
partially that and partially what they
are describing as
sex addiction which i i'm hearing in
cell as someone who's involuntarily
celibate
um but the point is i have no interest
in prematurely saying it's one thing or
the other
or neither or both what i know is that
the law enforcement law enforcement in
the u.s and the american right
will often characterize shootings by
white men
differently than they characterize
shootings by non-white men
that we know and because of that we're
sort of on alert
as we hear and try to determine what the
motive was here and there's no question
that
people often will play koi with terms
like terrorist
lone wolf and these other types of terms
in this case it's just early it's a
tragedy either way
but we know most of the victims are
asian now yesterday there was a
very strange press conference with some
of the police
and i'm going to play a clip for you of
captain jay baker of the cherokee county
sheriff's office saying that
the shooter had a bad day and he was at
the end of his rope
on the day that he killed eight people
and many people rightly reacting by
saying
this guy cherry the the guy from the
cherokee police jay baker
he almost sounds like more sympathetic
to the shooter than to the victims in
some strange way take a look at this
video
the investigators they interviewed him
this morning and i they got that
impression that yes he he understood
the gravity of it and he was pretty much
fed up and then kind of end of his rope
and
yesterday was a really bad day for him
and this is what he did are you worth
the pool
uh i'm not gonna go to i don't know if
he's remorseful or not
he was fed up and had a really bad day
and killed eight people just kind of
strange language for describing what
happened it almost sounds again more
sympathetic to the shooter than the
victims
i think that's the bizarre thing but
okay maybe race wasn't a factor we don't
know yet
and then maybe not shockingly after this
bizarre press conference we learn
that jay baker the georgia sheriff's
spokesman you heard from there has
previously posted
xenophobic coved shirts on facebook
where he said he loves his shirt and the
shirt is a shirt that says
covet 19 imported virus from
china c-h-y hyphen n
a so now maybe we're doubting what this
guy
says and then we get reporting from the
south korean newspaper chosun
which interviewed victims and reports
that the atlanta shooter
said to a witness or a witness heard the
shooter say
i'm going to kill all asians and we've
translated the article from korean the
reporter is huang ji yoon
uh it includes reports of interviews
with witnesses
and the quote that on the 17th the hong
kook ilbo
atlanta quoted an employee a
a member of the gold massage spa
where the shooting took place and said
that the suspect at the time of the
crime
said that he would quote kill all asians
it is known that this witness mr a was
in the store at the time of the shooter
shooting but managed to evacuate and
then gave this information to nearby
korean businesses so it's becoming
harder and harder to believe
that a guy saying he's going to kill all
asians wasn't at least partially
motivated by race
here is another clip in this one frank
reynolds a cherokee
uh county sheriff says that this appears
to be sexual addiction not racism take a
look
we did interview him last night he is
currently in our facility at the
cherokee county adult detention center
we were able to interview him with the
atlanta police department and fbi
he made indicate indicators that
he has some some issues uh potentially
sexual addiction and may have frequented
some of these places
in the past and but as the chief
indicated
is still early on we still have a lot of
things to process and
um so he should be at an arraignment
tomorrow at some time
early morning to late morning
and we will keep you up to date we have
a press release that captain baker has
put together
uh available to our our media folks uh
if you don't have that i think we have
some printed copies that he'll be uh
happy to give to you
i'm happy to answer any questions that
you may have for a moment so are you
saying
when you talk to the suspect he says he
has a sexual addiction
but i'm sure you asked him was this
racially motivated was this racially
motivated
um as the chief indicated it's still
early but the indicators right now are
uh
it may not be it may be targets of
opportunity
again we're we believe that he
frequented these places
in the past and um may have been lashing
out uh
and part of that is is in your media
packet as well but the working theory is
a sexual addiction issue rather than a
racial profile during our interviews
we asked that specific question and uh
and
that did not appear to be uh the motive
for for for
thank you according to authorities the
suspect
intended to also target the pornography
industry in florida
before he was apprehended and again the
statements uh we
there's a claim that the shooter said
i wasn't motivated by race or politics i
was motivated by my addiction to sex
the claims from the witness about i'm
here to kill all asians
certainly seem to contradict that now i
don't know that it necessarily has to be
one or the other
uh you could have someone who you know i
guess the term incel is sort of
pejorative but it's an individual
frustrated by his
um by his celibacy their celibate but
they don't want to be celebrated for
a variety of different reasons they're
unable to find relationships with
if you're interested in the opposite sex
as it appears this person was
members of the opposite sex it could be
both it could be racially motivated
and in cell motivated or more one or
more the other
so whether or not this was racially
motivated
there have been many racially motivated
shootings whether this one is racially
motivated doesn't change that
racially motivated shootings are a
problem in the united states
some people immediately said of course
this is racially motivated and anyone
saying otherwise is lying to you or
dishonest
others have been saying there's no way
this is racially motivated and we
shouldn't look for that
even some on the left in fact have been
saying stuff like that from what we know
so far there is certainly reason to
suspect
that race was one of possibly more than
one
motivation let's continue to allow the
information to lead us to the answer
i have no uh political
or emotional attachment to it being one
or the other
but what we do know is there at least
now is a report
of the shooter saying i'm here to kill
all asians
we will see what comes out we'll see
what else we learn about this sheriff
spokesperson who posted
xenophobic china shirts to facebook
every every detail continues to just be
more and more alarming
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
breakfast cereal that tastes
just like the sugary tasty delicious
cereals we loved as kids but without
the sugar and without the carbs magic
spoon
is sweet and delicious with zero grams
of sugar
13 grams of protein and only four
net carbs making it perfect for a low
carb
or keto diet this month magic spoon
is releasing two amazing new flavors
we're talking about cookies and cream
and maple waffle only available for a
limited time of course you can still get
cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon
build your own variety pack our team has
tried every flavor
we keep asking them to send us more
magic spoon is as good as it sounds
magic spoon ships to the us and canada
and you'll get five dollars off
and free shipping when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link underneath this video